[Music]
i love seeing a movie in imax and i love
seeing a big old
huge film on a big screen so this is the
famous suicide
squad that is a pure cinematic
experience
if there was ever a movie to go to the
cinema to see
it is this one the scale of this state
is huge
it's packed full of actions and plot
twists
[Music]
he does throw polka dots at people it's
a massive graphic novel
brought to life people are going to be
able to see
all of the magic and all of the
wackiness of dc comics
brought to the big screen in a way like
it's never been done before
being able to create the suicide squad
and for imax
specifically and to be able to shoot it
in that aspect ratio
was very exciting to me it's a great
balance of those moments of
poignancy and heart and humor
and badassery
this film is gonna blow people's minds
it's
such an experience wow and it's
definitely worth doing with good sound
and a big screen and a big crowd
you're never going to fully experience
the suicide squad
unless you see it in the theater
to be able to see it in imax is the best
way to see this film
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing
you